he's coach Hardaway Coach Hardaway now
no no longer penny how does that feel to
be called coach well I know in high
school coach in high school but Penny
Hardaway now coach Hardaway
congratulations oh thanks thanks a lot I
really appreciate it and it feels great
are you in the office now yes I am I
like it are you decorating what do you
what would you hang up in your office
that might surprise me I probably would
hang up a picture of the movie
Caddyshack because I love I love comedy
is one of my favorite movies Caddyshack
but no that would be something that
would be shocking or surprising that
would be hung up in my office did you
ever meet Bill Murray or Chevy Chase I
have not met either one No well maybe I
could arrange the Bill Murray one a few
if you want to yeah that'd be pretty
cool
do you guys face savior so it bills
bills son is an assistant coach there ok
so why don't you schedule Xavier and
then like you know you may not want to
play Xavier is go to Xavier's bin but I
know right how how would your game match
up with today's players in the NBA um I
think I was fair well because of now
most of the bigs are out on the
perimeter so in my game was explosive
and in an athletic play like we Russell
Westbrook's game like attacking the
basket so I think my game was fare very
well right now in today's game your kids
know what kind of career you had yeah
because of you - thank you - take me
back to the movie set when you're on
there with Shaq and Shaq and and Chris
Webber told the story so he says that
you know Shaq is telling c-webb we're
gonna take you number one overall and
then you're doing the movie blue chips
and all of a sudden you start playing
with Shaq and all of a sudden Shaq's not
calling Chris Weber anymore I was really
smart I mean I'm not smart in a lot of
areas but I was smart in this area when
I was doing the movie blue chips
spoon-fed check whatever he needed
whatever you want even think I took a
shot the entire movie I just gave him
every ball and said it's all about you
big fella and it worked and then all of
a sudden they take you number one
overall but here's poor C Webb he goes
shot kept telling me we're taking you
you know if you weren't in that movie do
you think he they probably would have
taken C Webb wouldn't they they
definitely would have taken C Webb
number one overall I mean Orlando he
went number one overall but Orlando
would have taken him for sure therefore
if I would not have been in that movie I
just did a good job of promoting myself
making sure the killer was always happy
the nickname penny explained that to us
I was born with copper copper skin and
my grandmother was like that's a pretty
pretty baby and the way that he said
pretty with her Southern drawl people
thought that she was saying penny and if
you'd have to be finished out to
understand that but she said I was a
pretty baby pretty as a penny you
imagine if your nickname was pretty
instead of penny oh my god and I was
trying to tell the guys I work with the
ad campaign you had with little penny I
still had the doll hear that yeah did
you do you have one I do have one okay
explain that ad campaign with Chris Rock
because it was huge and how was that
presented to you that they were gonna
have an ad campaign for Nike and it was
gonna involve a a doll with Chris Rock's
voice called little penny yeah well they
knew that I was quiet and I was uh when
I played I wasn't a trash talker but I
had major game you know I can back it up
which is my play they wanted to do an
alter ego that would talk so much smack
and the alter ego would talk there was
little paint he would talk enough smack
for me and I would go out and show it
with my own game so when they came to me
they presented it to them and I loved
the idea right away I just knew it would
be great yeah but did you feel like that
Chris Rock was saying stuff that you
wouldn't normally say obviously but then
did guys take it seriously what little
penny was saying about you know what but
what's in fact I got the doll here pin
so let me here we go so I got a let me
put it let me press Devon
anybody did anybody ever say that the
Secret Service couldn't guard me or did
you ever say that to anybody during a
game no I never said that anyway it took
a lot to rile me up and make me talk I
just showed you with my game but little
peeny did say some things that I was
saying them out loud that I was saying
in my head oh okay but you're but you
were never you didn't even with the guys
who were in the NBA at that time you
never engaged with you know Gary Payton
or Michael Jordan with trash-talking
maybe with Michael more than Gary
because Michael would kind of try to
push some buttons to try to get into my
head and we'd go back and forth and spar
a little bit not so much man Gary it was
just more about a chance match for Gary
and I but Michael would let me know
where he's to give me your Michael's
story that you tell I think he got
pissed off the year before when we beat
them and then the next year when he came
back and they went 70 72 and 10 here he
told me that you won't be you won't be
getting any more wins young fella he
basically told me like you guys are done
yes and he was right but they definitely
they definitely meant what they said
Continental Tire Coach's Corner the new
Memphis head coach Penny Hardaway the
jump from high school to college what's
the biggest concern for you I guess is
getting used to the players because this
isn't my team this is coach Smith's team
and I can just add some pieces along the
way getting used to getting guys to buy
into me that are going to stay and they
were recruited by another coach I've
never had that situation happened I've
always brought guys with me wherever I
went my team and built my team that way
on middle school in high school
so this is new for me and just really
just kind of having the kids that are
left over buy into what I'm going to
bring to the table the importance of
bringing some of your high school kids
to the Memphis team how many do you
think you're gonna get to commit to play
for you well I mean it's many they want
to come that you know that are capable
of turning the French I mean
the school around I mean I just hope
that I've left a lasting impression as a
coach and as a mentor on them that they
will want to follow me to Memphis if
their choice to go anywhere but I would
have hoped that I've had put that type
of an impression on I saw I saw one of
your high say one of your games this
year with your high school team and it
was early in the earth I mean that was
an impressive team give people an idea
of just how good your high school team
was no thank you I definitely appreciate
that but we have the number one arguably
the number one ranked junior 7-footers
name is James Weisman we have a six a
four word channel Lawson Chandler lost
his brothers were here at Memphis and
then they transferred to Kansas so
they'll be playing at Kansas next year
we have Alex Lomax who was mr.
basketball back-to-back years here in
the state of Tennessee we had a really
Ryan boy some signed with UAB we have
about eight or nine Division one players
on the team on my high school team
how many losses we had three losses
earlier in the year and we went on a 15
game win streak and won our third state
championship in a row what's the most
points you scored in high school in a
game I think I scored 71 come on seven
you did why didn't you pass the ball
penny I mean I had it going at night it
was my night day and there was a
three-pointer back then right yeah and
your high scoring game in the NBA was
142 in them against Miami and the
playoff series 42 if there was one
highlight you would say watch that
highlight and you get an idea of what
kind of player I was what would it be
see now if you schedule Georgetown and
you and Patrick can cross paths yes
that'll be awesome did you ever talk
about it like if you see Patrick would
you ever bring up that dunk you in
person you'd never do that when I just
speak I know you have
joking but I just speak and say how you
did you know all my things and then just
go along my little merry way but he's an
he's intimidating but he's a very nice
guy you know but back then I tell people
watch him when he was at Georgetown when
they played against Jordan in North
Carolina and Patrick went after every
remember they started the game I think
he blocked like the first six shots and
you know there was gold tending like
Ewing was like an incredible defensive
presence and then he became one of the
great offensive centers in NBA history
it was crazy yeah yeah that's amazing I
know coach Thompson was was imitated
about being the best defender because
I'm just I'm sure that's what he put
first and he was so raw in high school
and when he got to the NBA he worked on
his game and got his offensive game
going I'm watching Shaq is the trailer
on the play when you dunk on Ewing but
you can see shackle like he knows what
has happened like that's that's one of
those you just posterized Patrick Ewing
and not many people lived to tell about
it
well Shaq yeah we were definitely fans
in one another's games so whenever he
did something spectacular or special I
was his biggest fan and vice-versa for
me I thought it was cool that you sat
down in the 3430 and kind of hashed that
out because a lot of these things they
just stay stay there and you know in you
know that people their relationships are
lack thereof how tough was it to get you
two to sit down to kind of hash out what
went wrong in Orlando well you know it
wasn't hard at all once they call me I
was on board they call Shaq he was on
board and it was a easy easy easy deal
what did you learn from that that you
didn't know I kind of knew everything
but he did apologize to me for leaving
you know I always wondered you know what
made him want to really really leave I
can only assume things but for him to
apologize on national TV I thought that
was that was big of him hey well it's a
big move but it's a great move for
Memphis and hopefully it's a great
homecoming for you good luck we'll be
following it and thanks for joining us
thanks so much Dan I really appreciate
you that's Anfernee Hardaway penny for
more
and Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]